Шановні колеги це той випадок коли ми
хочемо подякувати співавторам цієї
постанови зокрема пана мотовиловцю за
правильне рішення яке розширює
можливість для депутатів опозиційних
фракцій брати участь в тимчасових
слідчих комісіях Але чому таке трапилося
що сьогодні у нас потрібно дозволити
депутатам працювати в двох тисках тому
що ця Рада перша В історії українського
парламенту
наплодила мільйон ТСК але що важливо
зауважити ТСК - це завжди механізм для
опозиції контролю над владою у нас в
країні сьогодні слуги мають всю повноту
влади воно більшість в парламенті тільки
слугами сформований уряд всі силові
структури на 200% свої прокурори
керівники дбр інших структур але мало
влади мало і слуги створюють ТСК які
самі і очолюють і ми бачимо що це
перетворюється ну всьо вчора вся країна
нарешті почула і дізналася прізвище і
обличчя такого народного депутата Гунька
який очолив ТСК по корупції по
розслідуванню корупції з землею в
державних установах і цю корупцію саме
очолив тому що його зловили на хабарі
85,000
$ щодо Землі яка належить
національній академії аграрних наук він
пішов далі ще й заблокував постановою
своєю закон який прийняла Верховна Рада
України щодо землі і більше правильно
використання цих земель ми Закликаємо
вас не порушувати парламентаризм тиск -
це механізм опозиції будь ласка
створюйте ТСК має очолювати опозиція
розслідуємо ці справи І не плодіть ТСК
заради папірців Вони мають правильно
працювати дякую